Another two.
I remember Chuck Norris versus Bruce Lee.
Yeah,
that's,
watch that real quick.
That's,
that's sensational.
yeah.
See if he can find Chuck Norris versus Bruce Lee.
I came on Hbo and my head almost blew up.
I made my mother get me HB all on the groove tube came up because the chicks ran
through the jungles with dit.
Group tube is cousins with Kentucky Fried Movie.
What is it?
I never even heard of it.
You can take a five minute.
No,
the groove,
that groove tube is saved to Bruv tube.
It's Saturday night live.
Before Sinai lie,
they made two movies called the Groove Tube and Kentucky Fried Chicken,
Kentucky Fried Chicken Doc.
If I move it.
Oh Shit.
Looking this.
This is the game though.
That's the game.
God Damn.
Look,
Chuck Norris taken off his black belt.
Look how young he is.
Bruce Lee.
This is a gay porn.
Look how slowly they on the roving.
Well,
this is the game and look at how we look at Charles North.
Chuck Narcis chest.
Charles Norris get his chest.
It's all hairy and shits before dudes figured out shaving your chest and when
you see this and then you don't like wrestling,
what do you think the big differences like movie mother fuckers want to see us
play?
This was Brian.
This was,
look,
I'll rip Brian.
This was something that you cannot imagine.
This was every nerd had a hero.
Every immigrant out here,
bro.
Everybody had a hero.
They're looking for kitten.
Look at the fucking kitten.
Everybody had.
That place has a million cats.
I've had the Roman Colosseum though.
Look what he's warming up.
That both warming up,
they're doing caught out a warm up for the fight.
Scenes are looking at each other.
This is the craziest fucking tremendous shit,
man.
America has to put these four movies on and realize why it stopped.
I'm Bruce Lee changed my life.
You only saw one fucking movie.
You got to see all four.
Forget the game of debt with Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
That's a harvest show.
Just watch this one.
Look at this.
That's what he does.
When he me out,
I was just one of the fight starts looking at him dog.
He had like 6% body fat at this time.
This guy wasn't gonna die.
Joe Rogan like this.
Don't die.
Don't fucking insult me.
He didn't die.
They killed this poor little kid.
But this is really fascinating.
I've never seen a movie that I recall where two guys warmed up like this before
a fight.
But that's,
but this is fascinating how they just don't even look at each other.
They move away.
They go in their own little fucking world for awhile and they meet in the
center.
Like these are,
this is a different thing than a fight in a movie.
You know,
like this is two guys agreeing.
We have to find out who's the baddest mother fucker alive.
You know,
they agree to do it the right way.
Everybody warms up.
Bruce Lee catches a good sweat.
So it was chuck,
this is crazy shit man.
I forgot how crazy this is.
Uh,
this is the beginning guys.
Well,
Joe and I am talked about the movies of 1973.
You really want to watch the shit today.
Go ahead.
But this is where it starts.
This is where all these movies are stolen from him and they can't even steal
them.
They don't know why they even did this.
Okay.
Bruce Lee,
he's getting into his fighting stance.
You're the cat.
Bam.
Okay.
The bolts were on front leg roundhouse kicks to open up with in front lake
sidekicks.
Okay.
No one's hit anybody that blocking everything.
Oh,
Chuck Norris scores or the wheel kick to the face and smiles.
It doesn't even follow up.
He said,
gentlemen,
okay.
No ground and pound.
Right.
Oh Shit.
Chuck is putting a beating on him.
Oh my goodness.
Oh,
Bruce Lee grabbed the god damn chest hair.
It's not fair.
It's rude.
Is this is also the beginning of tank pseudo when chuck Norris split from Chi
Taekwondo and he could recreated this shit.
Really?
Yeah.
He's a tank pseudo guy.
Yeah,
but he,
I don't think he created it while supposedly he had his,
his style.
I mean it was definitely a style,
but it existed before,
so they did two different tanks who dose,
right.
This tank Sudo Su bog doll,
and I think he went the other way.
There's a superbug Dole that they all,
they all started together,
but he went the other way.
Thanks.
You don't have a little bit of grappling in it.
Yes.
They had more grappling.
It didn't talk.
When doe did,
they had like some risks,
locks and joint locks and stuff.
Here we go.
So he gets his timing.
He starts talking,
jumping up and down and it's all fucking lights out motherfucker.
But the beauty of this is this is going to remind you something,
Joe,
just keep watching watching.
Oh Shit.
Isn't it dishonorable to grab some of these chest hair and Rick had off them
though.
When you were in the Colosseum,
whatever happens happens in this family.
You're trying to,
as long as you don't lie,
but watch all these,
watch all this is still slow mall.
Nobody knows.
Nothing pulled up.
How fake is this row of they're finding and look,
I'll thinking that brick wall was behind them.
They keep showing like a picture of the Coliseum and then a brick wall.
Okay.
This is crazy shit.
Chuck Norris and Bruce Lee,
they slow everything down.
This is hilarious.
The sound that it makes every time they throw kicks this hilarious too.
It's 40 years ago.
Look at the camera work.
The guys trying Matt.
Yeah,
he,
he's like,
kick the fucking camera.
He's trying.
He his up poster of the Roman Colosseum behind poster.
It probably shot this in Laurel Canyon.
Laurel Canyon.
Yeah.
Chuck Norris is watch his feet.
He kicks him in the face.
Oh,
chuck.
hands down.
Damn.
What?
Wow.
To chuck to shut it off.
Okay.
Beautiful Hair back then.
Hi.
Oh,
the oblique kick.
Look at them.
John Jones style son Bruce Lee was the first oh front leg round cake to the
face.
Chuck Norris goes down.
Had ever seen anything like this before.
Back then,
this didn't exist.
Never saw a fight and moved 11 and Tonya head almost blew up.
You left.
They're looking for somebody to say something to you,
was fucked him up.
Including your dad.
You didn't give a fuck when you left these movie theaters.
This Joe Rogan.
You know whether or not Bruce Lee ever competed in.
I mean that was like,
the big thing about him is that he never fought like Chuck Norris was like world
middleweight kickboxing champion at one point in time.
Bruce Lee definitely did a lot of spa for sure.
There's no way it could be this good.
The way his timing in his,
his movement,
his understanding of what would and wouldn't work like these in a lot of ways,
even though some of it is ridiculous,
some of his movements are more realistic than shit you see in the movies today.
The way he checks with that old bleak kick,
the weight counters when you're moving in,
it's very realistic.
Like these scenes like the ways fucking this dude up is a lot like the way
someone who is at a really high levels fucking somebody up in the UFC.
It's really a kind of ironic like the way he's the shit that nobody does.
This no bow.
That's a move and a half.
I told you in the 70s everybody swept Joe Rogan.
Everybody you had,
you had a watch that front leg you will getting swept.
Once you got into range and you'd throw two punches laid out that you were
getting swept dog,
everybody sweat.
The sweep has disappeared from our society.
He broke his thought.
Oh,
there you go with a fuck.
You think you're dealing with.
I was going to be your arm or his leg.
That's how my hand,
when I was out of the eight balls,
that's how I
check doors.
He did.
He broke his arm and his legs.
Legs fucked up too.
He fucked them up.
But listen,
watch.
This is a tremendous movie.
This is tremendous.
Guys.
Next time you see Chuck Norris,
don't looking dumb with the wig.
Think about this.
Think about this move.
Look dog.
He gets up.
Even though if it's a movie.
Bruce was very smart.
He goes,
let this fucking guy up was a great scene though.
It can't stand,
but he gets up.
This was a good fucking scene.
He gets up.
This is tremendous guys.
Look at him.
He's trying to throw kicks.
Can't get up.
Yeah.
I forget how it ends.
It he kill him.
Spoil alert.
Beautiful.
It's a beautiful day.
Even got up correctly with a fucking damaged leg.
Oh yeah.
Mother fuckers.
This is cinematography one o one.
You gotta make good teen.
Oh my God.
He killed them.
Logins him.
First time ever.
He's upset that he had to kill him.
Doug might might've the first gaiety never in a movie.
I believe.
Backing up a second,
I believe that was an RMN gear team,
which is particularly difficult to pull up.
I don't think,
uh,
I don't agree with this technique here.
Let me see back it up.
Just so here.
Is that an arm in?
Let's see here.
I can't see his other arm.
I feel like that's a arm and gear team,
which I call bullshit.
No,
it's not armed men is it?
It looks like it is.
It's hard to finish that one,
man.
You got to get up high on the neck.
Oh,
you got to have an unbelievable squeeze.
Let's see.
What do you get?
Nope.
I don't know.
Tough to tell where his arm was.
It was if Chuck Norris had the under Hook there,
it's very hard to,
well,
why don't turn it off.
Watch we does.
This is,
this is,
this is tremendous guys.
Which Steve was a fucking soldier and he wrote all these,
you know,
he wrote all of these though.
Look,
watch,
watch.
Oh,
the music plays.
Dusts off his Kung Fu Jag.
Yet,
by the way,
how many black guys dressed like that?
I turned 1970s and eighties had the full outfit.
My mom was gonna send me back to Cuba.
They sent me.
So Maria reappraising didn't know what was wrong with me.
Here we go guys.
This is no,
no,
no.
What happened there?
Just a youtube,
cause it's not the whole movie.
He goes and gets his G and puts it on back.
I'll be back on top of how his belt and makes it look nice for him.
Very nice.
Great fucking scene.
That's the guys.
Come on.
Do you think.